اه لميزات التنقل عبر التطبيقات وفي
مقدمتها جوده الخدمه بات الكثير في المغرب
يستخدمها بشكل لافت للانتباه مروان الذي
طلب عدم الكشف عن هويته وواحد من الاف
الشباب المغاربه الذين وجدوا في تطبيق
النقل مصدر رزق ينتشله من البطاله
بيد ان استخدام هذه التطبيقات طرح تحديات
عده مستعملها من السائقين يشتكون من فراغ
قانوني ومن علاقه ليست على ما يرام مع
سائقي سيارات الاجره
يعني قوانين دياله
في جميع الدوله
تطبيقات لكي تشتغلوا في احد الاعداد ديال
المواطن المواطنات يخرج على القانون ما
عندهم تلخيص وهذا الشيء اعتراف من وزاره
الداخليه ومن مصالح ديالها اذا تحرك
لايقاف هذا الامر هذا ما كاينش الناس
خدامها كاين قانون الغابه في المغرب
والناس كتشتغل يعني كاين واحد المنافسه
غير شريفه احزاب من الائتلاف الحكوميه
بدات تفكر في تحديث القوانين المؤطره
للنقل والتي تعود الى عام
1963 تلك القوانين يعاب عليها انها لا
تواكب التحولات الحاصله في هذا القطاع
نقوم دراسي غدا ان شاء الله
واحد 15 20 يوم في رقم الاغلبيه اللي غادي
تستدعي لها وزاره الداخليه وزاره النقل
باش يكون واحد المجال فيه الاراء باش
يشوفوا يمكن البرنامج مقترح قانون او
الحكومه
القانونيه دفعت شركه اوبرا عام 2018 الى
ايقاف نشاطها وكانت تشغل حينها قرابه
12,000 سائق مغربي
عمليا يشتغل اصحاب تطبيقات النقل في
المغرب لكن قانونيا لا توجد تشريعات
تؤثرهم ليستمر التنافس بين الطرفين على
لقمه العيش الى ان تقر الحكومه او
البرلمان تشريعات جديده المختار العبلاوي
الجزيره الرباط